zurück bei BILD am Gründonnerstag ja
ganz genau green Donnerstag alles rund
um das Thema Nachhaltigkeit nämlich bei
Bild und wir wollen das mit guter Laune
machen nicht mit erhobenen Zeigefinger
also mit dem Promi Quiz wer lebt
nachhaltiger dass Duell um die Zukunft
[Musik]
das Duell um die Zukunft heute wird es
Royal und rosig Prinz gegen Bachelor und
eine ganze Menge Wissen zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit gibt es noch oben drauf
ja
André Mangold ehemaliger
profi-basketballer dann als Bachelor im
TV richtig durchgestartet leben in einer
Traumvilla auf Malle und bis vor kurzem
noch dort Betreiber seines eigenen
Nachtclubs gewesen jetzt will er sich
ganz bestimmt grünerin und gesünderen
Themen zu wenden und macht hier bei uns
den ersten Schritt ein eigenes
Fitnessprogramm hat er schon mal sehen
wie fit er beim Thema Nachhaltigkeit ist
Prinz Frederic von Anhalt der Adelstitel
ist nicht angeboren aber dennoch umgibt
er sich in seiner Wahlheimat Los Angeles
mit dem hohes who Hollywoods er ist der
Witwer der schauspielerlegende Sasa
Gabor in den Staaten lebte auf ganz
großem Fuß und will jetzt bei uns im
Duell um die Zukunft beweisen dass er
auch ganz grün kann
ja also gut zugehört unsere Kandidaten
müssen fünf Multiple Choice Fragen
beantworten pro richtige Antwort gibt es
einen Punkt pro Punkt pflanzt bild 10
Bäume der Kandidat mit den meisten
Punkten gewinnt logischerweise bei
Gleichstand kommt es jedoch zur finalen
Schätzfrage so viel Druck hier
wie viel Prozent des Stromverbrauchs in
Deutschland kommen aus erneuerbaren
Energien
ah 23 Prozent aus erneuerbaren Energien
B 41 Prozent oder C
59%. was glaubt ihr ihr habt 10 Sekunden
ab jetzt
[Musik]
so Prinz Frederik sagt C André Mangold
sagt B wir haben unsere Sendung den
Green expert er hilft uns mal bei der
Antwort
erste Frage erster Punkt der Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien im Stromverbrauch
hier in Deutschland also Energien aus
eben solarkraftanlagen oder auch aus
Windkraftanlagen hat sich in den
vergangenen zehn Jahren mehr als
verdoppelt auf
41,1 Prozent leider ist es in
Deutschland noch nicht möglich den
gesamten Stromverbrauch aus erneuerbaren
Energien abzudecken da fehlt uns doch
die passende Infrastruktur die hat aber
zum Beispiel Island schon und da können
wir uns einiges von abgucken also
wirklich stark und wirklich stark auch
von Dir lieber andre 1:0
wunderbar damit geht der erste Punkt
eine andere sehr geschätzt wusstest du
das oder oder hast geraten nicht gewusst
nein Schätzfragen sind natürlich was wo
du ein bisschen Glück brauchst aber das
klang für mich wie ein guter Wert
wunderbar andere du er spielst uns die
ersten zehn Bäume darauf kommt an zweite
Frage Thema Mode was glaubt ihr denn
verbraucht bei der Herstellung das
meiste Wasser ist das A die Jeans die am
meisten verbraucht B dieser Tor Bluse
oder C ein T-Shirt was verbraucht am
meisten Wasser
so was haben wir denn was haben wir denn
der Prinz sagt zehn du sagst dieser Zahn
B ein Projekt der Hoffnung möchten wir
jetzt kurz präsentieren was aber auch
gleichzeitig die Frage mit beantwortet
schauen wir mal rein
Textilien sind aus Umweltsicht eine
echte Modesünde mit am schlimmsten ist
ein Kleidungsstück was nahezu jeder und
jede von uns im Schrank hat die Jeans
ein spanischer Textilhersteller will mit
seinem Produkt jetzt eine nachhaltige
Alternative anbieten terridos Royo hat
sich auf die Herstellung des Stoffes
Denim spezialisiert der Wasserfußabdruck
einer herkömmlichen 800 Gramm schweren
Jeans umfasst satte 8000 Liter Wasser
damit könnte man 50 Badewannen befüllen
der größte Umwelteinfluss bei der Jeans
Produktion geht von der Baumwolle aus
und das liegt an dem enormen Land und
Wasserverbrauch und dem CO2-Ausstoß der
damit verbunden ist
nicht nur der aufwendige und
wasserintensive Anbau von Baumwolle
macht den Klassiker aus dem
Kleiderschrank so Umwelt unfreundlich
auch der Prozess zur Färbung der
typischen Jeans und das hierbei
verwendete Wasser kann aufgrund der
Chemikalien selten aufbereitet werden 10
Jahre lang tüftelt das Unternehmen an
einer Technologie das Ergebnis dry
Indigo
wir haben drei Indigo entwickelt es ist
eine alternative Färbemethode mit Schaum
es ist besser als konventionell gefärbte
Produkte mit dieser Methode wird das
Garen ganz ohne Wasser gefärbt chemische
Substanzen werden hierbei um 89%
reduziert und auch der Energieaufwand um
65% geschrumpft außerdem recycelt das
Unternehmen alte Jeans zu neuen
Dämmstoffen wodurch die wertvolle
Ressource Wasser zusätzlich geschont
werden kann so sinkt der Verbrauch auf
gerade einmal
477 Liter Wasser pro Jeans nochmal zum
Vergleich eine herkömmliche Jeans
braucht dabei 8000 Liter das ist eine
Reduktion von
[Musik]
94%. so muss keine auf das
kultkleidungsstück verzichten
dass das kann passieren wir kommen zur
nächsten Frage jetzt müssen wir Bäume
sammeln wie viel Prozent des
Plastikmülls in Deutschland werden
wiederverwendet a 16 Prozent B 42
Prozent oder C 91%
. ist da jetzt wieder ein Werte
schwierig
ja so viel oder geht so viel
ja machst du das ja ich habe es auch
machen so ich muss aber fairerweise
sagen andrehen das war keine zehn
Sekunden
eins zu eins aber wir wollen natürlich
trotzdem wissen was die richtige Antwort
ist Kira hält und zwar weiter es wäre
wirklich so schön wenn du richtig liegen
würdest lieber Frederik aber tatsächlich
sind es nur 16 Prozent unseres
Plastikmülls hier in Deutschland der für
neue Produkte wiederverwertet wird alles
andere landet in Verbrennungsöfen oder
wird auch ins Ausland verschifft so
zumindest laut dem plastik-atlas und man
darf sich nicht täuschen lassen die
offizielle recyclingzahl hier in
Deutschland liegt bei 45 Prozent diese
beinhaltet aber nur dass der Müll zu
einem Recycling-Unternehmen gebracht
wird und nicht dass da wirklich neue
Produkte daraus entstehen da geht noch
mehr
aber das ist eine schmalerei ist müsste
mehr sein 10%
so was hätte ich gerechnet ja und was
außerhalb des Zeitlimits du lagst
daneben wieder keine Bäume außerhalb des
Zeitlimits wenn wir Bäume pflanzen
wollen dann müssen wir uns aber noch mal
Gedanken machen
ähm Bäume deswegen Pflanzen wir sie ja
sind wirklich wahrlich Lebensretter ja
weil sie CO2 binden durch die
Photosynthese die sie brauchen zum Leben
und bei diesem Prozess aus CO2 normalen
Sauerstoff wieder machen ja also diese
Augen quasi dass ich den Schmutz aus der
Duft ein und produzieren die Luft die
wir halt atmen können und um Thema Bäume
handelt sich jetzt auch unsere vorletzte
Frage wie viele Bäume in diesem Fall
normale buchen ja braucht es um eine
ganze Tonne CO2 zu binden ja auf meine
Güte aufgepasst das ist echt nicht
schwere Frage ist echt nicht schwere
Frage glaubt Verein 20 CO2 braucht es
zehn Bäume B 30 Bäume oder C 80 Bäume
was meint ihr ihr habt 10 Sekunden ab
jetzt wie viele Bäume für eine Tonne CO2
Tonne
sind die Karte 10 Sekunden Frederick
schnell
wunderbar was hast du B Frederik du
sagst C und bei dir was bei dir was eine
Panik Antwort ich habe glaube ich dir
zur adiebauer selbst gedacht Hilfe hilf
uns auch immer weiter okay gib mir wir
brauchen Bäume na geht doch lieber
Frederick jetzt auch der erste Punkt für
dich und hier die Erklärung dazu pro
Jahr bindet zum Beispiel eine Buche ca
12,5 Kilogramm CO2 das heißt um jährlich
eine Tonne CO2 zu kompensieren brauchen
wir 80 Bäume sollten allerdings keine
Jungbäume sein die haben nämlich noch
weniger Blätter an den Ästen und
dementsprechend kann weniger
Photosynthese stattfinden deswegen auch
die Bäume die ihr hier in der Sendung
ihr spielt die brauchen noch ein paar
Jahre um auf diese tollen Werte zu
kommen
großartig mega schwere Frage es steht
eins zu eins kommt mir vom Land und ich
kenne mich so ein bisschen mit Bäumen
und so willst wie ich ich ich war da
schon so ein bisschen drin das gab mir
das Gefühl und dann habe ich nachgedacht
mal gehört du verstehst du das das soll
es aber keine Ahnung
meins hat nicht funktioniert gerade
ich beleidigen
so welche Fleisch Alternative hat den
höchsten Proteingehalt ah Seitan
B Tofu oder C die Jackfruit a Seitan
Beethoven C Jackfruit kann ich überhaupt
gar nicht sagen ja
und so wir haben Prinz Frederik sagt
Antwort B er tippt auf Tofu und was
sagst du da dazu aber ich habe ehrlich
gesagt ich habe keine Ahnung weißt du
was seitan ist
weißt du ich auch nicht
leute ihr müsst doch Seitan kennen der
Fleischersatz hier zum Beispiel in
meinem Döner der aus Weizenmehl und
Wasser hergestellt wird und übrigens
richtig viel Eiweiß hat 25 bis 35 Gramm
bei Tofu hier z.B in einem Curry sind es
nur 10 bis 15 Gramm und die Jackfruit
die hat leider am wenigsten nur 1,1 g
Eiweiß allerdings muss man dazu sagen
sie hat ganz viele andere Nährstoffe und
schmeckt richtig lecker vor allem als
Pulled Pork Ersatz aber in unserem
Eiweiß Game hier da ist der Seite an der
klare Sieger und damit andere ein Punkt
für dich 2:1
ja aber das ist nicht richtig dass ich
wusste nicht was es ist dass die
Jackfruit verhältnismäßig wenig hat und
das Tofu geht so hat und deswegen dachte
ich mir sein dann klingt extrem gut so
liebe Zuschauer falls Sie sich wundern
was wir in der Hand haben das sind Zeit
haben Burger und die Probleme jetzt mal
würde ich sagen
[Musik]
es geht für mich ein bisschen in die
chickenrichtung und das ist ja nicht
schlecht also Baden schmeckt es
überhaupt gar nichts
Liebe und das ist es nicht zu wenig Fett
zu wenig Fritteuse zu wenig Öl wir
feiern andere Mangold ja du Masters Quiz
gewonnen du hast das Duell um die
Zukunft gewonnen ich habe direkt einen
Pokal für dich bist bereit ich bin sowas
von bereit das ist ein roter Ahorn geil
seit ich glaube 50 Einheimischen
Deutschland danke schön heißt das Ding
Leute
[Musik]
auf der wunderschönen Insel da habe ich
einen schönen Garten und da kann ich den
auf jeden Fall Pflanzen ich muss mich
aber vorher mal erkundigen ob das das
die tropischen Welten oder da überleben
würde herzlichen Glückwunsch an Dich
vielen Dank Frederik du hast knapp
verloren ich bin cool am Anfang der
Sendung haben wir über eine grüne Aktion
gesprochen die sich der Verlierer
überlegen darf um die Welt ein bisschen
grüner zu machen du fährst glaube ich
ein relativ dickes Auto oder ich fahre
ein schönes Auto ja ich bin ja auch ich
gehe auf die 80 zu ich bin 79 Jahre alt
für was brauche ich eigentlich auch ein
Auto ich habe zu Fuß ich laufe hier in
Berlin das heißt das heißt zehn
Kilometer das heißt wie lange willst du
das Auto verzichten
ich brauche gerade 12 Zylinder mehr den
brauche ich nicht gibst du momentan
du verkaufst im Rahmen des Duells um die
Zukunft jetzt deine G-Klasse ich darf es
beim Namen nennen oder
ich fahre die G-Klasse so lange
seitliche G-Klasse gibt ich werde Auto
versteigert und den Gewinn werde ich an
irgendeine Charity Stiftung oder
irgendwo hingehen unfass das ist doch
sowas unfassbar und du hast wie gesagt
durch deine zwei richtigen Antworten 20
Bäume mit Hilfe von Idealo erspielt
André Prinz Frederik ich bedanke mich
bei euch das war's von der heutigen
Folge Duell um die Zukunft wir sehen uns
nächste Woche wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
super Sache oder gibt ein ganzes Auto
Herbert hinter mir ein bisschen Angst
guck mal da ist
dass sie meine Ruhe da ja aber das
Windrad
beobachten wir weiter so was jetzt
weniger Fleisch essen ne jetzt zur
Mittagszeit ja das wäre gut für den
Planeten das wissen wir alle aber leider
schmeckt vielen Menschen ja so ein Tofu
Stückchen eben nicht ganz so gut wie so
eine schöne knackige Bratwurst also
suchen Wissenschaftler nach Alternativen
und werden fündig und jetzt geht's hier
um ein völlig neues Lebensmittel und das
besteht nicht aus Pflanzen und nicht aus
Fleisch sondern aus Pilzen
Brathuhn Wurst und Rippchen erfreuen
sich nicht nur auf der wiesengroßer
Beliebtheit aber Fleisch belastet eben
leider auch unser Klima denn 18 Prozent
des weltweit Ausgestoßenen co2s
entstehen bei der Fleischproduktion doch
es gibt Hoffnung ein völlig neues
Lebensmittel es schmeckt genauso gut wie
Fleisch braucht aber keine Weideflächen
und hat eine spitzen CO2-Bilanz das
Geheimnis dahinter sind Pilze und das
beste ist sie fressen das was beim Bier
brauen übrig bleibt also rettet jeder
Schluck Bier bald das Klima auf unserem
Planeten
das will ich mir ansehen deshalb fahre
ich nach Hamburg dort sitzt das Start-up
marschlips die drei Gründer Maaßen risk
ti Bogo da und kathi-preiser entwickeln
hier den neuen super Fleischersatz es
besteht aus pilzwurzeln dem Mützel im
Untergeschoss liegt das Lebensmittel
Labor hier züchtet tibogo da Pilze die
sehen aber ganz anders aus als die
Pfifferlinge im Wald wir nehmen dann
zwar die Pilze aus der Natur dann nehmen
wir diese diese Würze aus dem Pelz und
lassen das hier irgendwann in einem
reinen Umwelt dann wachsen und dann
gehen wir weiter wir brauchen jetzt
wenige Tage damit das bisschen Pilz
praktisch diese ganze Maschine hier
ausfüllt richtig genau also der wirksam
war weiter hier vermehrt sich und wenn
es hier voll ist in dem Gefäß dann wird
es dann in den Fermenter überführt in
dem Fermenter wird alles kontrolliert
das heißt der Pilz wächst in unter
optimalen Bedingungen direkt über dem
Labor werden gerade Fleischbällchen aus
Myzel in der Versuchsküche zubereitet
wegen hat das schon so eine Fleisch
Assoziation wir müssen uns hier nicht
darum kümmern wie wird das Tier
geschlachtet weil wir haben einfach ein
Pilz der muss nicht geschlachtet werden
der hat keinen hohen Wasserkonsum der
braucht keine landenutzung keine
kombizide Pestizide also wirklich ein
viel nachhaltigeres Produkt im Endeffekt
und kommt mit einem super ausgeglichenen
Nährwert Profil wir haben viel Vitamine
Mineralien andere Nährstoffe also es
sind insgesamt sehr gutes Produkt was am
Ende immer noch super gut schmeckt das
ist für uns das Wichtigste dr maasten
grisk hat mach schleps gegründet er
erklärt warum Lebensmittel aus
pilzwurzeln so gut sind er ist ein
Pflanzen seit tausenden von Jahren wir
essen Fleisch der tausende von Jahren
warum müssen wir jetzt noch Pilze essen
weil wir essen Pilze acht seit tausend
von Jahren und Pilze sind in Natur ein
sehr natürliches Produkt wie wir
probieren durch unsere Technologie nur
einfach das effizienter zu machen und
global zu produzieren wir brauchen dafür
weniger die Waffen weniger Zeit ist es
nachhaltiger und wir können pro
Quadratmeter mehr essen produzieren als
eine normale Fläche
marschlips hat eine Kooperation mit
einer großen Brauerei geschlossen
zukünftig werden die Reste aus dem
Brauvorgang an die Pilze verfüttert das
heißt bald rettet Bier trinken also
unser Klimabilanz ein bisschen
jedenfalls
na dann ein Post auf die Pilze
[Musik]